so
if I said oh I want you to all catch the
bus
and it's it's going to be just outside
there just outside those doors so that's
why I went into way then the bus comes
and it stops over there but because she
was told
stand there you're standing there
waiting the bus the bus goes off
and you're left not on the bus and you
go well I don't know we were told to
stand there
so whoever told you
didn't check to make sure where the bus
really stopped right so that's a simple
analogy about what I'm saying and so
what I'm doing is I'm watching some of
you seeing this
Ellen alone
let's watch some of your seniors do this
right you're doing that and then you're
doing that
but this is the part
where the bus stop
is wrong because you can see my head
is wider than that gel isn't it
you'll see that my head is wider than
that job
so there's two answers here one is why
would I put it out there if it wasn't
to protect my head now is it protecting
my head
but is it also protecting my shoulders
so to me
this is
correct
so cytos agency now initio sentencing
who was a great great sauce master as
well they're all passed away now
but
he was he was born like this
but Saito said she said
why would you block
what is the block for so that would be
one answer and he'd say it's to block
your upper body
from a downward strike
you would put it out there they would
protect your head and your shoulders
from being hit
this protects nothing
what this does is it just Blends so
how many skins
it just lands the gut with his job
these shows are danger this is the
dangerous thing using that job
but what happens if someone's watching
not the youngsters but I was putting
some of you before seen or seniors if
you do this
are you kept on the same line all you've
done is avoided being up you've gained
nothing from it
what so if you gain from it
so we might all say yes we know that
we know we don't but so if my theory was
uh
I wouldn't have gained anything
to protect myself against his life okay
but that does
here
so that's one of the facts huh I'm
getting off the line once the whole
principle like you know always get off
the line
if it comes from a speed to it from a
from a muskeg to a stomach
off the line I can take my whole body
a big half of my husband in the wrong
place get on with that huh it's a pretty
good chance he's gonna get something
isn't it
so my thing about telling children wait
there for the bus stop
is giving them bad information
because I'm researched enough
so a lot of you and you three especially
were going one
two
three so you're not protecting yourself
against two attacks
so really you're not protecting yourself
with three things and that is
the biggest thing as out of your life
don't let anybody know you
get off the line
and this at the right angle will protect
you from a ski or a stripe so you've
covered two two probabilities you
covered whatever we eat in decided
your head's protected so there's two
things and I get off mine
that's protection